joining me now is Mark Houck who is a
pro-life activist whose home was raided
by the FBI last September he's also
running for congress in Pennsylvania uh
Mark good for you does this surprise you
given your own experience and
what do you think should happen at this
point to Chris Ray first of all I'm a
Roman Catholic I don't know who they're
talking about these traditional radical
Catholics I guess they're just people
who believe in Roman Catholicism at this
point
yeah well it's obvious to me two things
are happening here Laura the first thing
is director Ray is not doing his own
personal investigation as it pertains to
my situation because I was rated by the
FBI surprised I wasn't shot like Mr
Robinson and he did not do a personal
investigation as it pertains to the
Richmond memo or the second thing he
flat out perjured himself before the
oversight committee either way he it's
clear that doj is targeting people of
faith and declaring them enemies of the
state
well if you see this and you think this
can't be happening in the United States
of America where religious liberty is
sacrosanct and our free exercise rights
protected under the First Amendment so
you know the Liberals Love The
Establishment Clause but we also have
the free exercise clause and it seems
marked that religious beliefs are under
attack on in a whole host of ways this
article you're not going to believe this
called a devout Catholic couple claims
that Massachusetts ban them from
participating in the State foster care
system due to their religious beliefs
they claim that the state restricted
them due due to their adherence to
Catholic teachings on gender sexuality
and marriage
Mark um
well something like this has to be
challenged and ultimately make its way
to the Supreme Court but do you ever
think would arrive at this day in the
United States of America when something
like this could happen
look I I woke up one Friday morning
prepared to take my children to their
homeschool Co-op I had a quiche in the
oven and at 6 30 in the morning I had a
pre-dawn raid with heavily armored FBI
agents 20 plus law enforcement I could
never imagine that my children would be
woken up in the middle of a slumber and
that their father would be arrested and
accosted in front of them and taken away
in shackles so yeah it doesn't surprise
me what's happening in Massachusetts I'm
not surprised people who want to foster
kids that are in the system they have a
great heart they have a Generous Heart
and to be to to to deny them because of
Faith makes absolutely no sense to me
well in Catholic adoption agencies of
course have closed down because of their
faithful beliefs as well Mark you were
the best person on this tonight thank
you so much hey Sean Hannity here hey
click here to subscribe to Fox News
YouTube page and catch our hottest
interviews and most compelling analysis
you will not get it anywhere else